with nine Off the Bench Bronson with
seven Tatum with four assists develop
his 14 points blowing a tire as he took
it inside the lane
Boston oh here we got some shoving
finally welcome to the Conference Finals
right okay we talked to Joe mazzua
before the game the Boston coach said we
need more physicality we've got to show
some toughness and maybe this is part of
that whole scenario well that's why you
play guys like Grant Williams yeah right
to me he's got a great physicality about
him he's certainly not going to back
away from any of the physical stuff and
again let's address there is no love
lost between these two franchises when
you've seen each other numerous times
over the years in the playoffs you have
built up an animosity and this is going
back to the Paul Pierce kg days and
LeBron James and Dwyane Wade there's a
history here between these two
franchises